في كل مره ومناسبه انكر النظام الايراني
تزويده روسيا بالاسلحه والمسيرات التي
تستعملها لقصف البنى التحتيه ومنشات
الطاقه الاوكرانيه
فكل التقارير والتحقيقات كاذبه وبلا اساس
من الصحه كانت تقول طهرا ايران كررت نفي
قيامها بتزويد روسيا بطائره مسيره
لاستخدامها في الحرب ضد اوكرانيا قبل ان
تعود لتقر بذلك
الجزء الثاني
المزعم التي لا اسس لها من الصحه و بانها
نقلت مسيرات لاستخدامها في الصراع في
اوكرانيا من المخيم للامال ان تحاول هذه
الدول اطلاقا حمله تضليل ضد ايران خدمه
لجندتها السياسيه
ايران لم ولن تقدم اي سلاح لاستخدامه في
حرب اوكرانيا
اتفقنا مع وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه على
ان يقدموا لنا اي دليل لديهم حول استخدام
روسيا لطائرات بدون طيار ايرانيه في
اوكرانيا
وكانت الضغوط الدوليه المتناميه استمرت
متهمه طهران بارسال المسيره الى ساحه
القتال في اوكرانيا
الدليل على استخدام المسيارات التي باعتها
طهران الى روسيا ضد المدنيين الاوكرانيين
واضح مثل الشمس
حكايه المسيره الايرانيه في اوكرانيا عرت
كذبه نظام ايران وجعلته في مرمى عقوبات
دوليه جديده بسبب تدخلها في الصراع
باوكرانيا الى جانب عقوبات سابقه بسبب
افعالها فيما يخص زعزعه امن واستقرار دول
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وقمع الاحتجاجات وخرق
حقوق الانسان بالاضافه الى البرنامج
النووي بلال الوجداني العربيه